the scale of destruction here is really
quite unbelievable like something out of
a war zone or a
disaster film rather than a village on
the outskirts of east london and yet
here we are um looking at complete
devastation these are some of the 20 odd
houses that have been
destroyed by the fire as you can see
completely gutted what's left in there
is just a pile of rubble a few charred
rafters
and in here you can see a bathtub the
remains of an ironing board a few
radiators completely charred but inside
you can just see right through to the
field beyond and and if you look up um
well there's there's nothing but sky no
roof at all remains just the shell
of these houses um the fire was so hot
in some places that it caused what's
called spalling where the concrete or
brickwork actually cracks because of the
heat of the fire is also so strong that
it jumped from here
over the road
and set fire to this side of the road
and then the flames spread across the
road across the field
uh uh to that building over there and
and the buildings actually affected were
largely um it was really a bit of a
lottery it was just depended on which
way the wind blew but in total around 20
uh buildings uh destroyed
it took a hundred firefighters eight
hours to get this blaze under control
and earlier the the borough commander
for havering for london fire brigade
told me that he'd never seen anything
like it well it's unprecedented you know
we've had grass fires for for years you
know we've always dealt with them but
this was unprecedented this involved
buildings and um
you know it's just it's something that
we just you know we wouldn't expect to
see in france you see in spain you know
places like that and you just uh
you
you know you think oh you know we don't
we don't get those things don't happen
to us
but all of a sudden now you're looking
at you know looking across the uh
this scene you're thinking wow you know
the web our summers are getting hotter
could it happen again
of course it was happened once so yeah
yeah definitely
fire officials have told us that some of
the people whose homes have been
destroyed in this village are actually
still on holiday and so haven't yet seen
what remains of their homes while others
of course don't forget will have fled
here on tuesday as the flames approached
with nothing but the clothes on their
back so really do have nothing left all
they have is is the rubble where their
home once stood
even though it's now five days since the
fire we've only just been allowed access
to the village because of the threat
of reignition and fight so firefighters
have spent the last five days damping
down the embers and the ashes to ensure
there are no lingering hot spots and
even though the area is now considered
safe for the public to return it's clear
this village has changed forever